hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the magnus
carlton invitational semifinals it's
magnus schultz and versus yaniponishi
and this is their third game of the
match first two games ended in a draw
and the third one is quite uh
quite uh a feisty one uh so without
further ado let's
check it out and see what this is all
about and it features uh one of my
favorite moves that
were ever played but that we're we're
going to get back to that
so magnus with the white pieces opens
with d4
now we have knight to f6 by on we have
c4 e6
knight to f3 and d5 so nothing out of
the ordinary just normal queens gambit
declined
knight to c3 and now d captures and c4
uh the vienna variation we have e4
striking in the center preparing e5
and here black goes b5 sort of a modern
idea trying to give up the the b5 pawn
for the e4 pawn nothing
nothing's really going on there so
instead we have
e5 magnus chases away the knight knight
to d5 and only now
knight captures on b5 so now white grabs
the pawn
uh and knights the b6 now i'm defending
the c4 pawn so white
can't really develop uh easily with
bishop to e2 and now
knight to c6 nepo just continues
developing pieces
uh we have castles and now uh bishop to
e7 nepal now ready to castle we have
queen to d2 as you can see
black has some issues in in developing
this bishop you could develop
it to e3 but the magnus has different
plans so he first starts with queen to
d2
uh and now bishop to b7 uh we have
brooke the d1
now the d4 pawn is nicely defended uh
and here
queen to d7 preparing the castle maybe
king side maybe queen side also putting
some indirect pressure to that knight on
b5
so here uh magnus just brings it back
nice to c3
uh also the knight cannot be shifted to
e4 it's gonna be a very strong piece
there
and now knight the b4 so what do you do
here
uh here uh the the game has been reached
before it's been played in the saint
louis rapid tournament in 2019 between
dingle
and fabiano corwana where quinta f4 was
played by ding
uh that game ended in a draw but here we
have a3 by magnus and it is only now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game so the knight being chased away
we have knight to d5 as that was the
plan all along and
now comes knight to e4 the knight is now
excellently placed covering all of these
squares
not that one obviously uh and it's a
it's a fine piece
so here queen to c6 we reach the
position from the thumbnail where you
can see that the queen and bishop
battery
could do some serious damage if the trio
of knights are you know
removed from there so you have to be
very careful uh we have rook to e1 by
magnus and now nipple castles queen side
we have bishop to f1
tucking the bishop back in for later
also the bishop now serves as a nice
defender to the g2
pawn so you don't have to worry about uh
you know
that uh we have f5 by nipple now
asking magnus do you want to move the
knight and then allow me some
very nice attacking chances with just
pushing my pawns or do you want to
capture alba
and uh allow me to open up the g file so
here he captures we have g
captures now nipple with the semi-open g
file he can use for attacking purposes
uh and now a magnus needs to continue
developing somehow and he needs to get
the bishop back
not back with the bishop into the game
so he can connect the rooks and
well find some sort of a game plan one
way to do it is queen a5 followed by
bishop to d2 but magnus chooses uh
a different path he plays queen to e2
now the bishop
will get developed uh and now uh we have
king to b8 a nice prophylactic move by
nipple
uh we've bishop the d2 uh and now comes
uh
rook h the g8 now uh if possible nepal
wants the double rooks and the g
file and create an attack against
carlson's king
so here we have rook 8 to c1 putting
additional pressure on the c4 pawn
and bishop to d6 now now asking do you
want to capture
it would be very dangerous to have this
bishop remain here it's a very strong
piece
and now it's a well basically a question
do you want to capture it right away or
do you want to play knight to the c5 and
maybe allow the the the capture to
happen there but first
magnus is in no rush he's just gonna
play g3 uh
not allow this bishop to cause any any
huge problems and also it will be a nice
defender of
the rook or rooks that come to the g
file so here
f5 chasing away the knight with knight
captures on d6 now
and c captures on d6 so now nepal fixes
his pawn structure and
improves his presence in the center and
uh although you could capture an e6 it
could be
could be a bit dangerous to allow uh you
know the rooks to occupy the uh
that e file uh but uh you know
maybe it can be captured but magnus
decides against it even though the
engine does recommend it magnus starts
with bishop to g2 he puts
some pressure along this diagonal and
now rook d
to e8 now nepal immediately defends it
uh we have knight to h4 by magnus now
opening up this bishop's diagonal and
the queen to b5 nepal gets out of the
way we have rook to b1
defending the b2 pawn and now queen to
b3
so what do you do here magnus plays
bishop to c3
guards everything here but he's also
trying to sacrifice a pawn if nepo
accepts this captures captures and
captures
then magnus finally has the open b file
he's going to start with a4 a5 he's
going to try and create an attack on the
queen side
but nipple of course not interested in
this he does something else and here
nipple played a most interesting idea
uh after carlson's bishop to c3 nepal
played knights to f4
and now uh he's attacking the queen he's
attacking the bishop there's a double
attack on the bishop
uh this is what i mentioned when i said
one of my favorite moves as knight to f4
if you've
been following our uh 1960 world
championship series where uh mikhail tal
challenged mikhail botwinick to
to the world championship match uh
knight to f4 is
when it when it all really started so
knight f4 by nepo and now it's not easy
declining this your queen is under
attack
if you don't accept the knight you have
to move the queen and for example if you
move it
you're just going to play knight
captures and after knight captures
white will have to suffer as this bishop
along with this entire diagonal is just
a monster
so instead after knight to f4 we have g
captures on f4 the knight must be
captured
and now rook to g4 that was the whole
point
uh the knight is undefended and there is
no way to defend it so
h3 you could go back of course knight to
f3 it is possible
uh but the then comes knight to d5 or
rook eat the g8 and there's really
nothing you can do here
so instead magnus gives it back uh with
uh style he plays
h3 now forces the trade but also unpins
the bishop so
rook captures uh bishop captures on b7
and now king captures and now queen to
f3 with
check we have king to a6 and here magnus
thought
okay his king isn't run it's now or
never i have to
start an attack king the h1 is a is a
nice safe move here a4 is also a very
nice move here but magnus
starts with the very aggressive d5 uh
opens up some
uh opens up the the diagonal for his
dark square bishop but also it's upon
sacrifice so
let's see what he had in mind here uh
nipple played knight captures on d5 and
magnus now played
rook captures on e6 removing the
defender of this knight and he thought
okay i have the queen i have the dark
square bishop i have
still my rook which somehow might enter
the game
uh this could be could be winning and
nipple says okay
let's see it rook captures queen
captures and now comes
rook to g6 with check king to f1
and now there is only one move that wins
the game for nepo
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this
great idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
uh finding this uh well idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen to b5
queen to b5 is the only move that wins
because you have to go into an end game
not only that you have to stop white
from uh achieving some sort of a
perpetual checking pattern uh because if
you play
anything else for example you play
something like rook captures on f4 or
some sort of a move then
uh queen c6 check and you are never
getting out of checks queen b6 check
your
uh you're going to block with queen to
b6 you're going to get queen to a for
checking b7 you're going to get
checked here and now again if you go
here then here uh basically white always
uses this diagonal to deliver checks
uh and then of course if king to b8 then
queen to e8
check and now if king to c7 then okay
queen to e7 check you go back
king to b8 queen to e8 to check and then
again you use this diagonal to
deliver checks so this is what you have
to avoid nepal found queen to b5 this is
what he played
and now magnus does not have any sort of
a check here or any sort of a useful
check here
and he's going to be forced to trade
queens and go into most unfavorable end
game so here
rook to d1 magnus defends the queen
and now nepo just captures we have rook
characters group captures and now
rook captures on f4 also defending his
f5 pawn
uh bishop to d4 uh and now comes
rook to f3 going after the h3 pawn with
bishop to e3
and now even f4 just chasing away that
bishop
uh we have rook to f5 now with a double
attack here of course if
you capture the pawn then the rook is
gone so rook to e6
so what do you play here uh bishop to d4
the bishop needs to move out of the way
so bishop to d4
and now comes rook to e4 now forcing the
bishop to move once again we have king
the g2
a nice in-between move attacking the
rook and rook to d3 now we have bishop
to c3 by magnus
now uh the bishop is safe but here comes
d5 with d4 being unstoppable
uh and there's really not all that much
for magnus to do here rook f6 check was
played king to b5
and now rook to f7 but here just d4
and magnus needs to play something he
played bishop to b4
and here nipple played rook to e2 going
after the b2 pawn and he was in this
position on move 45 that
magnus carlson resigned the game and
nepo takes
the lead in this match uh so we'll see
what happens
in game four but uh jan has excellent
chances here of
winning the day one as he has the white
pieces in the final game
and here we resign you don't really have
a good move here the pawn cannot be
defended
there's not much you can do you can
capture on a7 but then rook captures
here
and the two connected past pawns are
simply too strong and let's not forget
uh black is up upon and still up the
exchange
so very very impressive showing by
nipple it was basically a drawing
game and magnus overestimated his
chances a little bit
and he was extremely low on time but
nepo took advantage of that very nicely
and now he's in the lead and we'll have
we'll see what happens uh
later on uh so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
uh klaus moral
muller nielsen uh robert kiefer uh
congratulations to lucasfilmman for
matching
chessboost.com and gregory rossolimo for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the
uh magnus cross and invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day